- I think the secret to my career is,
I don't know what I can't do.
These things happen to you,
and you think you've been
dealt a terrible hand,
or you've had bad luck,
and when you just go with it,
you just start improvising,
suddenly you realize that you stumble upon
some of the best things that
have ever happened to you.
Or success is a little
like a white tuxedo,
it looks good, but you're very
afraid of getting it dirty.
And it can inhibit you.
- He's an American TV
show host, comedy writer,
and television producer.
He's best known for hosting
several late night talk shows.
Since 2010, he's hosted Conan
on the cable channel TBS.
He's Conan O'Brien,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules to success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite.
And make sure to stick around
all the way until the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
make sure to leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
- I think the secret to my career is,
I don't know what I can't do.
There are times when I should
probably sit and think,
do I really want to jump out
there with Phillip Seymore,
I mean with John C. Reilly,
and sing The Night Chicago Died?
Or do I really want to play
the blues with Lil' Ed?
And you just do it.
You just do these things.
- [Charlie] And the audience
wants you to do these things?
- Yeah, I think what's,
I don't know what it is,
but I think over the years
people have gotten
comfortable with the notion
that I try things.
- [Charlie] It's almost put to (mumbles).
- And they're not worried about me.
Do you know what I mean?
I think that's the key.
People aren't worried
about me getting hurt.
I'll give it 100%,
and then if it completely
falls on its face,
I'll laugh about it and move on.
And I think there's a
little bit of a sense,
after all these years, people say,
"All right, he tried it.
"Maybe it worked, maybe it didn't work,
"but he had a good time."
- And for you, you can
come back the next night,
and the next night, and the next night?
- Yeah, I mean that's,
I don't know.
Over the years I've realized
that there are a lot of comedians
that are very worried about
keeping their dignity intact,
and keeping their personal space,
and keep their sense of authority.
And for better or worse,
and it might be worse,
I don't have that.
Do you know what I mean?
The people that I've
always liked growing up,
and I'm not just talking about late night,
I'm talking about anybody
in movie, in film.
The people I liked, Peter Sellers, they--
- [Charlie] Would let it all hang out?
- They just go.
If you look at a lot of those
old classic Carson clips,
he's jumping into hot
tubs with Don Rickles,
he's jumping through fake walls,
he's falling on his ass,
he's dressed as Floyd Turbo.
So sometimes I look back to that.
And I remembered,
"Well, Johnny just went for it."
So for better or worse, I'll try.
I'll get out there.
I'm very physical.
My wife is always horrified.
I'm always coming out of the shower
just covered in bruises.
And she'll say, "What was that?"
And I'll say, "Oh, I did a bit.
"We had Jeff Garlin on the show,
"and he and I rolled
down a flight of steps.
"And I hit a fire hydrant."
What astounds me is how many
young people come up to me
and say, "Conan, someday I'm
going to be on your show."
- [Charlie] Me too.
- And I say, "What is it you do?"
They don't know.
That's the crazy thing.
Most people, it's the
Paris Hilton phenomenon,
they just want to be famous.
And they've actually seen it work.
They've seen someone get incredibly famous
for just being famous.
So that's a little unsettling sometimes.
But mostly, what I've noticed,
or what I would say to people is,
"You've got to go to where
they're making the thing
"that you like, and then
work there in any capacity."
"If you have to get coffee for somebody,
"if you have to hold a cable,
"if you have to stand there and volunteer,
"go to where they're
making the thing that you,
"that moves you, that gets you excited,
"and try and get close to it."
I mean, I remembered for years I was aware
that I'm not doing the
thing that is going to be
my life's work, but I'm close.
I couldn't even tell
you exactly what it was,
but I knew I was close.
Do you know what I mean?
I knew when I was a writer
at Saturday Night Live,
"This isn't quite it, but I'm close."
I knew when I was a
writer in the Simpsons,
"This is further way from it
than I was at Saturday Night Live."
I knew that I liked being
around the live performing.
So I knew when I was close.
And that's what I tell them,
is just go there and don't
have any ego about it.
There's so many channels
now, so many stations.
- [Charlie] That's
exactly what I tell them.
And just get in the arena is the idea.
I mean, if you get it,
80% or 90% of it is getting in the arena.
- Get in there and do it.
And eventually, the Brownian
movement of molecules,
eventually you getting in there
and putting yourself out there.
If you have something to offer,
someone's going to see it at some point,
and you're off and running.
So many people come up to me and say,
"Now that you've made it,
"don't you just want to stick
it to some of those people?"
And I think no.
Because they weren't wrong,
we had our problems in the beginning.
This had to be a long process,
that's just the way it had to be.
And I prefer it this way.
I was raised Irish Catholic.
I had a sense of wanting to earn it.
And there was nothing
that was more difficult
than being proclaimed
Letterman's successor,
and having everybody have
this uneasy sense of,
"Who is he?
"Should he have this?"
- "And what has he ever done?"
- "And what has he ever done?
"And why does he get to do this?"
And maybe this whole
process was just necessary.
This was my way of earning it.
And I think a lot of the
confidence I have on the air now
is because I went through
a very difficult period,
and there's nobody out there who can say,
"Gee, he had it easy."
I mean, I'm famous for having to overcome
a lot of obstacles in
front of people on the air.
And so I'm comfortable with
the way it all worked out.
- When did you decide you
could professionally silly?
Did you get a glimmer of that at Harvard,
that you were taking Cairo?
- Yeah, well the Lampoon
was a big influence because I was,
you don't learn to be funny,
you don't learn to be silly.
A lot of what you are or who you are,
in some respects is decided,
I think, early in life.
You get the basic ingredients.
To me, when I was a kid,
and I think we all do this
in one way or another,
I ran through the list, "What do I have?
"What do I have?
"What are my skills that will help me?"
A, not get picked on or beaten up.
And that's in my own family.
And B, that maybe get the
attention of that girl I like.
Those are the things
that are operating on you
in this very elemental level.
Those are the things that
you're thinking about
when you're young, and you're a kid.
"Am I good athlete?"
No, I was a terrible athlete.
"Was I incredibly good looking,
and all the girls liked me?"
No.
I had this laundry list of
things I would go through,
and then I had this one thing,
which was I could make people laugh.
And so what happens, I think,
you find the thing you're good at,
and in my case it was so glaring.
It's not like there were
a million other things.
There was this one thing.
And if I had been a pretty
good baseball player,
I wouldn't be here today.
So I kept hyper-developing.
You could say I was hyper-developing
a defense mechanism.
And if you look at a lot
of artists out there,
that's probably what a
lot of them are doing.
My father, who is here,
and is a brilliant guy,
once said to me, "I get it now.
"You're making your
living off of something
"that should probably be treated."
(Conan and audience laughs)
And he's right.
And then a tear.
But a wealthy tear.
Not important.
Don't pursue wealth.
(audience laughs)
But that is something
that I think many of us do,
in one respect or another,
is we double down on
the thing that we have,
that we have to offer.
- You don't consider yourself
in the late night war,
so to speak,
because you're on at 12:30
rather than 11:00 or 11:30?
- I don't feel that,
sometimes I'll bump into
someone on the street,
and they'll say, "Hey, good
luck in your war against Dave."
And I'll think, "I have no problem."
I'm on after Dave.
He's doing a good show.
And I wish him well.
And I'm not in competition with him.
Sometimes I'll see
cartoons in the newspaper
of I'm wearing boxing gloves,
and Dave's wearing boxing gloves,
and I think, "I'm not--"
- [Charlie] You're not in the same place."
- "I'm not boxing anybody."
But no, I don't really feel like I'm,
I don't feel like I'm in
competition with anyone else.
I most of all feel like I'm
in competition with myself
to do the best show I can do.
The last three and a half months
has been all improvisation.
The groundswell of internet support
from a lot of young people
that are in this room
completely took my network by surprise,
they don't know what hit them.
I think there's a lot of
people in broadcast television
that are very dismissive,
or have been very dismissive
about the internet,
and they're all so afraid of it.
And they tend to deride
what they don't understand.
So when this explosion
happened on the internet,
when they announced that,
"Well, okay, maybe we're
going to slide Conan
"over to accommodate this other gentleman
"who's having difficulties
in another time period."
And I won't get into specifics,
you'll have to look it up.
(audience laughs)
And I said, "You know what?
"That doesn't really work for me."
I think in a fairly polite way.
There was suddenly a huge
reaction from people,
some of the people in this room,
a lot of people like you
across the country said,
"Wait a minute, we like this person.
"And this person kind of is,
"we're with him."
And they started reacting on the internet.
And the first thing that
happened at my employers'.
They saw this huge
explosion on the internet,
and they thought that I was doing it.
And they really had this
attitude of, "Make him stop.
"Why is he doing this?"
And they just didn't
understand what was happening.
I think they still don't
understand what's happening.
And my feeling is,
what I've learned is I
had nowhere else to go,
so I started on Twitter,
because I literally had no other option.
I was and am legally
prohibited from appearing on
television, radio, and doing
performances on the internet.
So I was just literally like a prisoner
in a 14th century cell,
writing little things on a scrap of paper
and throwing them out the window.
And hoping a peasant would
by, "Eh, what's this?
"He's in the tower."
So I started to do that,
and send out these little things.
And it exploded overnight.
And at first I started to
hear a little bit of stuff
from the other side saying,
"We're not sure you should be allowed to,
"because of the,"
and then they realized the absurdity
of shutting down my Twitter account.
So that started with that.
And then I started to
think about the tour,
which I'm allowed to do.
And so we started this idea for a tour.
And then what was fascinating is,
by the time we launched the
tour, or announced the tour,
I did not do one,
I didn't spend on penny on advertising.
I sent out one tweet that
directed people to a website
where you could buy your ticket.
That was it.
And the show sold out in a couple of hours
across the country.
And that's got everybody, a lot of people,
rethinking how things are marketed.
And there's not one billboard.
I didn't have to go one radio station,
and sit with morning DJs,
and hawk my show.
I didn't have to do any of that.
It was one tweet.
And I think people were
starting to understand
that the world has completely changed.
And it has, it is staying.
"And I think we can do better."
Sorry.
- That was great.
- I forgot I wasn't running for something.
But I think that's what's,
the biggest lesson that I've learned
in the last three and a half months is,
it's just a good life lesson.
And I'm not trying to
sound corny or anything,
but these happen to you,
and you think you've been
dealt a terrible hand
or you've had a bad luck.
And when you just go with it,
you just start improvising,
suddenly you realize that you stumble upon
some of the best things that
have ever happened to you.
And what's interesting about Twitter,
is that because you're limited to,
I think it's 140 characters.
Someone's going to correct me right now.
"Not so."
(audience laughs)
You're all going to rush the stage.
Beat the crap out of me.
But because you're limited,
it's actually a great comedy writing tool.
You're forced, there's
this economy of words,
so I'm constantly writing things,
and then I run them past Bleyaert,
Big Bley, who's taking
the pictures over there,
as if he doesn't have enough photos of me.
And he'll say, "Well, that's
actually three words over."
And it forces you to look
back at the sentence,
and it forces you to
crystallize your comedy idea,
which is fascinating.
And the other thing is I've been,
this whole tour wouldn't have happened.
This tour is a dream come true from me.
I've always wanted to,
it's half rock show, half comedy show.
And then it's this
fantasy to get to do this.
So the last three and a half months
have been the most interesting
time in my entire career,
and I wouldn't have traded
this for anything in the world.
And so three and a half months ago,
it looked to everybody like bad luck
has become amazingly good luck.
And I think that is a lot of what we're,
what relates to everybody here.
A lot of you are in your twenties,
and you take for granted that,
well, this is the way
the world is right now.
But from my perspective,
it's changed dramatically
in just seven years.
And I don't even know
where we're going to be
in five years from now.
So I don't know what
television's going to be
five years from now.
There's a lot of people that think
you're just going to experience
it all through your server.
And people don't even know how
the business is going to change.
There might not be, really,
network television as we know it.
Wouldn't that be sweet?
(audience laughs)
So you know what I mean?
Who knows?
Seize the day, carpe diem.
I hate it when people say
carpe diem, I really do.
I just wanted to work it in.
I'm going to keep talking to you.
Ask me another question.
Expect difficulties is something
I think everybody in this
room has gotten into Harvard.
Some of you who probably
are here snuck in,
but I don't care.
Let's just say for point of argument
that everybody here got into Harvard,
and you feel this incredible
pressure to succeed.
And I gave a speech here back in 2000,
and at the end I said,
"Fame is a little like a
white tuxedo, it looks good."
Or, "Success is a little
like a white tuxedo.
"It looks good but you're very
afraid of getting it dirty.
"And it can inhibit you."
And I think I would
tell my 19 year old self
that everything you're feeling right now,
I used to think that if I could
look at someone like myself,
I thought they had figured it
all out, and they were fine.
And wouldn't it be magical
if I could have my own show,
and be funny, and everyone knew who I was,
and most people liked it?
That will be a great thing,
and it would solve all my problems.
And I would like my future self
to say that's not the case,
it's actually day by day,
how you do your work,
how you conduct yourself,
how you treat people,
the joy you get out of your work.
That that is far more important.
And I'm not saying that as like,
to try and take away from,
I'm really proud of some of
the things I've achieved.
But I wish I had not put
myself so low in the totem pole
when I was 18 or 19 years old,
and thought that these other people
who were sitting up on stage talking,
knew so much more than me,
and had happy, problem-free lives,
because that's not true.
I'm not saying that to depress you.
I'm actually trying to say that as a way
to sort of liberate yourself a little bit.
It's not allow for mistakes,
allow for problems.
I've had my career blow up on
me about two different times.
And I'm still here, and very grateful.
And I learned a lot during those moments,
and wouldn't really change
a thing about any of it.
And so I think Harvard, as great as it is,
can sometimes instill,
and I don't think it's,
no one's telling you this,
it's just subliminal.
A lot of you have this is,
"I have to do great things,
"and I need to succeed."
And you just have to
be willing to screw up
and not freak out when you do screw up.
'Cause you will screw up.
I mean, you're really going to screw up.
It's in a week.
We'll talk later.
What I'm doing is I've
made a conscious decision,
I'm not going to try and do what they do.
I didn't spend this summer
going to comedy clubs.
I'm a real person, I'm
just going to go out there,
and say things that I think are funny,
and just be Conan.
And I think that so far,
I go out there and I'll tell a few jokes
or stories every night,
and the audience laughs,
and they're things that I think are funny,
and I think I'm presenting
them in a way that's honest,
in a way that it's just Conan.
It's just Conan talking.
And that's all I've ever
wanted from this show.
I just want this show to be,
my only goal is that I
get myself out there 100%.
If people don't like that,
and don't accept that,
I'll say, "Well, that's all I can do."
- But sometimes it's even hard to do that.
I mean, it's hard to make sure
that you are natural and comfortable,
and that what you are--
- That's what takes time.
I mean, it took Dave a while.
It's going to take me a while too.
It's a very strange thing to say,
"What we'll like you to do is go out there
"and just be yourself,
completely uninhibited,
"on a set in front of cameras,
"200 people in the audience,
"and we'll critique you every night.
"And critiques will watch
"for when you rub your finger together,
"or touch your nose,
or anything like that."
It takes a little while
to become completely
unselfconscious in that environment.
- How is it different today
in doing your show late night
than it was 10 years ago?
Are you more instinctive?
Do you think less about
it, and just do it?
- Yeah, it's muscle memory.
- [Charlie] It is.
Like the golf swing.
- You crunch down.
And you're constantly trying to learn.
You're still thinking,
but your ratio of thinking
to acting is very different.
At the beginning, I was
thinking about it this much
in my cognitive brain,
and then there was this much,
just whatever thin reed of
talent you have is there.
And then you're thinking about the rest.
And then over the years I think,
they always say the reptile
portion of your brain
is where respiration, heart beat.
That's the stuff that even if
you're knocked on conscious,
it still working.
I really believe a lot of my
talk show or comedy instincts
are now in my reptile brain.
That you could knock me out,
and my heart would still beat,
I'd still breathe,
and I'll still be asking Lindsay
Lohen some stupid question.
- You have become,
some way as part of your DNA,
it's become part of your DNA.
- Yeah, I think a lot of it is,
you have to have some ability.
But then it's just how much will.
I really do think there's just,
I think people underestimate.
It doesn't sound sexy.
It doesn't sound cool.
- How much do you want it?
- Work ethic.
And just how badly do you want it?
And there have been many times
throughout the years of doing my show,
where I've thought, "You
can shoot me in the chest
"before I walk out there,
"and I'll still walk out
there and do that show.
"And then I'll come backstage and die.
"But we're doing that show."
- It's been a lifelong dream
of mine to touch your hair.
(audience cheering)
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
about you working here.
- I've solved that problem.
- Guys, no more touching
questions, please.
- What are you talking about?
Yes.
Let's touch it up.
I'm sorry.
I feel really crass.
I don't even know your name.
Can I just know your name?
'Cause later on my wife's going
to be like, "What happened?"
"I don't know, I don't
even know her name."
"What did you do?"
"We rubbed out heads together."
What is your name?
- My name's Kelly.
- Hi, Kelly.
We should've done this before we rubbed up
against each other.
Hey there internet.
Conan O'Brien here.
Now, a lot of people
have been calling me out
on this ALS Ice Bucket Challenge.
I just want to say I accept.
This sounds like a really sweet deal.
Apparently if I get ice
water poured on my head,
ALS will then pay me $100.
That's a pretty sweet deal.
I could use that cash.
Let's do it.
All right.
Wow, that was cold.
Okay, ALS send the check to Conan O'Brien,
care of the accountancy firm--
- [Man] Hello, you don't get paid.
You get dunked and pay.
- I pay?
- [Man] Yes, it's a charity.
- Why would I do both?
- [Man] Why would anybody
be giving you $100?
- 'Cause I got a lot of ice
cold water poured on me.
- [Man] But it's a charity,
they're not going to give you money.
- So I don't get paid anything?
- Do you need $100?
- That's ridiculous.
- [Man] Do you really need $100?
- That's stupid.
Hey, well guess what?
Psych, ALS.
Check this out.
Plastic ice.
That water was a balmy 92 degrees.
I felt nothing.
Oh, that was real!
(Conan screaming)
- [Man] Okay, you got
to challenge people now.
- Oh yeah.
I challenge Jimmy Carter,
Paley, Harry Joel Osment.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
David Mares asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what did Conan say
that really inspired
you, or motivated you,
or had an impact on you.
What was the most important
message you got from this video?
Leave it down on the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
I'll see you soon.
- Well, lowest moment,
you were actually part of.
I was on the air for
about two months, I think,
and Chevy Chase had just been canceled.
And my staff was happy.
They said, "Oh, at least
we've outlasted Chevy Chase."
And I remembered saying,
"You don't understand.
"The critics just destroyed one show.
"There's blood in the water now,
"they're going to look
who's next in line."
They didn't have to look very far.
David Letterman replaced by
this guy from total obscurity,
and the show had a lot of flaws.
They weren't wrong.
I was new, and was making
rookie mistakes on the air.
So they came looking for me.
And I was on this show,
I'm thinking it's maybe October, November.
- Yeah, exactly.
You haven't been on long.
- Of 1993.
I haven't been on long.
You had me on the program.
And we shot it in the morning.
And you started the interview by saying,
"Conan, I don't know if you've seen
"the Washington Post this morning,
"but Tom Shales reviewed your show."
And then you started to read this review.
- [Charlie] What a cruel thing to do.
- Well, I respected you
for doing it at the time.
That's how I get most of my information,
is being told by other talk show hosts.
And so I read the review,
and then went back to my office.
And climbed underneath
the desk in my office.
And laid down for a while.
- [Charlie] Put a blanket over your head.
- No, I didn't.
I just laid down.
And I have very long legs,
and they stuck up from
underneath the desk.
And the word got around the office
that Conan is on the
floor underneath his desk.
And I remembered there
being a lot of murmuring.
And the producer of our show, Jeff Ross,
leaning in and said, "You okay?"
And I went, "I'm okay.
"I'm just under my desk,
but then I'll get out."
And then from there,
I really do believe that
I wanted to do this show
more than anybody else didn't want me to.
And I knew we had the elements.
I knew that we had all the
elements of a good show.
I had a very creative,
and still have a very creative
and adventurous writing staff.
Andy Richter's a very funny guy,
and there's not a presence
like him on television.
The Max Weinberg 7 is an amazing band
that can play swing music,
but can also play rockabilly,
they can play funk.
They can do anything.
And I knew that we have all the elements.
And I knew that I had the elements,
they just weren't all there yet.
It's like a baby skull
has to come together.
Isn't that a nice vision?
- Just a baby skull.
- Yeah, I really like a baby skull.
- I think I told you the time,
as you reminded me,
just to stay on the field.
- That's what you told me.
You said that, "Remember
what Joe DiMaggio said,
"'Stay on the field.'"
And at the time, I walked
out of here and said,
"What an ass.
"What an idiot.
"What's he talking about?
"Stay on the field."
- That's me or Joe DiMaggio?
- Both of you.
I love you both together.
I have contempt for anyone
who's achieved anything.
But it's good advice,
which is keeping doing your show.
And the network put
through my paces a bit.
And they put me through somethings.
- [Charlie] One week extensions.
- Yeah, I was being renewed
hourly at one point.
- "You can do this show, but no more.
"We're not making any promises
"after this show."
- "We'll let you know
"in 40 minutes, if you're
still a talk show host."
- [Charlie] "We may
jerk you doing this show
"if it doesn't go well."
- But I remembered a lot of
people saying at the time,
"Well, I wouldn't stand for that.
"I'd walk out."
And I remembered thinking,
"No, I'm going to stay here
"and do my show,
"and people are eventually going to see
"that we've got something here.
"And I'm going to get better at this."
I do think I have ticks and mannerisms.
And I think sometimes
there's a tendency these days
to think we've got to
get rid of all of those,
and be just a completely smooth performer.
And what I think is nice.
No, my voice isn't perfect for TV.
I mean, can't you tell?
There's things about me
that aren't perfect for TV.
There are times when you can see
that I'm just a little throne.
Or you can see that I touch my nose,
or I do something like that.
And sometimes I think,
"Don't get rid of all that."
In a way, I think I'm
just a real person, and--
- Because it makes you authentic.
- Yeah, I think it's real.
Again, I say if for any
reason down the road,
NBC would decide, "Well,
this show didn't work."
I'm proud.
I think the humor reflects my sensibility.
I think we're going for
the music and the guests
that reflect my sensibility,
for the most part.
And we're doing the show I wanted to do.
And so I would not feel bitterness or sad.
I would be sad because I enjoy
doing it, if it were to end.
But I think we're doing what I want to do.
There are few things more
liberating in this life
than having your worst fear realized.
I went to college with many people
who prided themselves on
knowing exactly who they were
and exactly where they were going.
At Harvard, five
different guys in my class
told me they would one day be president
of the Unites States.
Four of them were later
killed in motel shootouts.
The other ones briefly hosted Blues Clues
before senselessly in yet
another motel shootout.
Your path at 22 will not
necessarily be your path
at 32 or 42.
One's dream is constantly evolving,
rising and falling,
changing course.
This happens in every job.
But because I have worked
in comedy for 25 years,
I can probably speak best
about my own profession.
Way back in the 1940s,
there was a very, very
funny man named Jack Benny.
He was a giant star, easily
one of the greatest comedians
of his generation.
And a much younger man
named Johnny Carson,
who wanted very much to be Jack Benny.
In some ways he was.
But in many ways, he wasn't.
He emulated Jack Benny,
but his own quirks and mannerisms,
along with the changing medium,
pulled him in a different direction.
And yet his failure to
completely become his hero
made him the funniest
person of his generation.
David Letterman wanted
to be Johnny Carson,
and was not.
And as a result,
my generation of comedians
wanted to be David Letterman.
And none of us are.
My peers and I have all missed that mark
in a thousand different ways.
But the point is this,
it is our failure to
become our perceived ideal
that ultimately defines
us and makes us unique.
It's not easy.
But if you accept your misfortune,
and handle it right,
your perceived failure
can become a catalyst
for profound reinvention.
So at the age of 47,
after 25 years of obsessively
pursuing my dream,
that dream changed.
For decades in show business,
the ultimate goal of every comedian
was to host The Tonight Show.
It was the holy grail.
And like many people, I thought
that achieving that goal
would define me as successful.
But that is not true.
No specific job or career goal defines me,
and it should not define you.
In 2000, I told graduates
to not be afraid to fail,
and I still believe that.
But today I tell you that
whether you fear it or not,
disappointment will come.
The beauty is that through disappointment
you can gain clarity,
and with clarity comes
conviction and true originality.
Many of you here today
are getting your diploma
at this Ivy League school
because you have committed
yourself to a dream,
and worked hard to achieve it.
And there is no greater cliche
in a commencement address
than follow your dream.
Well, I'm here to tell you,
that whatever you think your dream is now,
it will probably change.
And that's okay.
Four years ago, many of
you had specific vision
of what your college
experience was going to be,
and who you were going to become.
And I bet today, most of you would admit
that your time here was very different
from what you imagined.
Your roommates changed,
your major changed,
for some of you your
sexual orientation changed.
I bet some of you have changed
your sexual orientation
since I began this speech.
I know I have.
But through the good,
and especially the bad,
the person that you are now
is someone you could never have conjured
in the Fall of 2007.